SPEAKER: Google has built
a Cloud Platform that
supports many industries,
and health care
is one that is top of mind.
Supporting from data
scientists to developers
to enable interoperability
across multiple data sources
and data types, such as HL7,
DICOM, FHIR, et cetera, as well
as leverage machine learning
while also being able
to be compliant
with regulations.
The intention has been to
accelerate the growth of health
care applications that
can provide interconnected
experiences, harmonized
data insights,
and are easier to build,
store, and manage.
And so in this episode of this
Cloud Solutions Healthcare
series, I will give
you a quick intro.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now let's say you are a
hospital with multiple sites.
As your patients move from
one hospital to another,
how do you bring all their
data together longitudinally?
Or maybe you are an
insurance provider
and want to adjust and analyze
your patient information
in bulk, as well
as enable patients
to have a safe and convenient
access to their data
to make more informed
health decisions
via their smartphone devices.
You could also be an
application vendor
who wants to make medical and
imaging records more seamless,
yet safe to access
between health care
providers and their patients.
Or you may be a
research organization
that wants to
leverage clinical data
to make models for predicting
breast cancer or diabetes.
If so, today you face many
challenges because data
is highly siloed.
And on top of that,
the stakes are
high if you don't align your
data processes to government
regulations, which could incur
very expensive fines for not
understanding new
policies as they evolve.
This is where the Healthcare
API and Google Cloud's HIPAA
compliant tools help reduce
that friction, since it offers
a platform for the
medical industry
to process data into
desired formats,
build upon the required open
data norms, aggregate and store
data into available schemas
that you can train ML models,
and have systems that make
data portability easy.
It also has a growing
public dataset
program that you can leverage,
such as chest x-rays or cancer
imagery.
From a security
standpoint, Google
follows a unique
zero-trust model,
which has multiple layers of
security from our data center
all the way to your browser.
And all products stated
in the terms of service
are HIPAA compliant.
We know how sensitive
your data is and want
to process it under your terms.
It's also important to know
that customers, and not
Google, own the data, and they
can take it with them any time.
Google has been committed
to serving the health care
industry and has been building
products and solutions
for not only our own doctors,
but also sister Alphabet
organizations such as
Verily, Calico, Google
Brain, et cetera.
If you're interested in learning
more in the next few episodes,
I will dive deeper into specific
solutions the Cloud Healthcare
platform offers.
You can also leverage
the resources
I have linked in this
video's description.
For now, if you found
this episode helpful,
friends, please click
Like or subscribe
to the channel
for more episodes.
Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]